[Música]
el senado de Estados Unidos aprobó una
ayuda de 45.000 millones de dólares para
Ucrania una suma que se integra al gasto
de 1,7 billones de dólares aprobado para
el aumento en la inversión militar con
que se contempla entre ellos misiles y
equipos de logística
una poderosa tormenta invernal azota
buena parte del territorio de Estados
Unidos el fenómeno climático ha
provocado Que las temperaturas
desciendan hasta los 50 grados bajo cero
cerca de 2000 vuelos han sido cancelados
más de 100 millones de personas han sido
afectadas
y el presidente electo de Brasil Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva anunció el nombre
de al menos 16 de sus próximos ministros
entre los que hay varias caras conocidas
de la política brasileña hasta ahora
seis de las carteras han sido asignadas
a mujeres
muy buenas noches Bienvenidos a las
noticias de France 24 soy Santiago López
González Gracias por estar con nosotros
hasta ahora vamos a comenzar en Estados
Unidos entre el paquete militar de ayuda
que este país norteamericano enviará a
Ucrania se contempla una batería de
misiles Patriot entre otros artefactos
militares tendrá un papel decisivo
entonces en el desarrollo de la guerra y
qué implica esto para el terreno Y la
batalla lo vemos a continuación
el viaje de boladimir selensky a
Washington se saldó con un millonario
paquete de ayuda militar para Ucrania y
no hay duda de Cuál es la pieza central
[Aplausos]
de casi dos mil millones de dólares y el
elemento más fuerte de este paquete es
el sistema patreon reforzará
significativamente nuestra defensa aérea
es un paso importante en la creación de
un escudo aéreo eficaz para Ucrania
el sistema de misiles tierra aire ha
sido fabricado desde 1976 por el grupo
armamentístico estadounidense raiden
saltó a la fama durante la Guerra del
Golfo de 1991 y ha sido un equipo básico
para el ejército estadounidense y muchos
de sus aliados Ucrania recibirá una
batería contiene 4 misiles pack 2 como
un alcance de 160 kilómetros o 16
misiles pack 3 con un alcance de 40
kilómetros kiev que la adquisición del
sistema patreon cambie las reglas del
juego en la guerra con Rusia
permitiéndole rastrear y derribar mejor
los misiles balísticos pero una sola
batería tendrá un efecto limitado
los sistemas que ya tienen los nazam los
Santi los Iris no pueden funcionar
realmente bien para eso están los
Patriots y francamente si el objetivo es
el microarquive un sistema desplegado
alrededor de kiev no va a alcanzar esos
objetivos no van a acertar esos misiles
necesitarán muchos más Patriots
hasta que Ucrania no aumente su
capacidad con los patreon es poco
probable que los nuevos misiles tengan
un efecto decisivo en la guerra pero sí
una mayor capacidad para repeler los
ataques cierto alivio para la población
de kiev que sufre frecuentes bombardeos
el presidente ruso Vladimir Putin
desestimó el potencial del sistema
patriart y criticó la ayuda
proporcionada a Ucrania
el sistema Patriot es bastante viejo no
funciona como nuestro sistema de defensa
antiaérea s-300 los que se enfrentan a
nosotros dicen que es un arma defensiva
muy bien lo tendremos en cuenta
pero siempre encontramos un antídoto
Así que la gente que está haciendo eso
lo hacen en vano no sirve más que para
prolongar el conflicto
y Estados Unidos vivirá una vida más
fría desde 1980 así lo indicó el
servicio meteorológico al anunciar que
la mayoría de los estados se verán
afectados por una tormenta invernal que
ya está provocando un descenso
considerable en las temperaturas previo
la temporada navideña cerca de 2000
vuelos han sido cancelados Andrés
triviño tiene los detalles
Estados Unidos vivirá una vida más fría
en cuatro décadas casi todos los estados
del país sienten los estragos de la gran
tormenta invernal Elliot la cual deja
más de 90 millones de personas en alerta
máxima principalmente en el medio oeste
y la región de los grandes lagos por lo
que las autoridades han estado a sus
ciudadanos a tomarse en serio la
tormenta
no es un día de nieve normal como cuando
eran niños en serio y mi equipo está
listo para ayudar a las comunidades a
sobrellevar esta tormenta
se espera que Durante los próximos días
Elliot se convierta en una bomba
ciclónica con ráfagas de viento tan
fuertes que pueden alcanzar el
equivalente a un huracán categoría 3
provocando hasta 30 centímetros de nieve
y temperaturas entre los 10 y los 20
grados bajo cero este jueves Más de
2.200 vuelos fueron cancelados y se
espera que la situación empeore tanto en
las vías como en los aeropuertos siendo
una de las festividades en las que los
estadounidenses más se movilizan debido
a que tenemos que más despacio tenemos
que establecer programar o reducir
nuestro horario
ha sido un poco loco llegué temprano
para asegurarme de tomar mi vuelo y a la
puerta de embarque cuando me enteré que
Fue cancelado las aerolíneas
estadounidenses anunciaron que trabajan
para que Los viajeros puedan reunirse en
Navidad y eliminarán las tarifas de
cambio a Los afectados por la tormenta
y a menos de 10 días de asumir el cargo
el presidente electo de Brasil Luis
Ignacio Lula dio a conocer parte de lo
que será su gabinete de ministros entre
los nombramientos se destacan algunas
figuras de la escena política brasileña
también representantes de los pueblos
afrodescendientes e indígenas hasta
ahora hay seis mujeres más detalles en
el informe de Rafael Pérez
son los primeros nombres del gabinete de
Lula el presidente electo de Brasil
anunció a 16 de sus nuevos ministros que
asumirán junto a él el primero de enero
los ministerios asignados fueron entre
otros Salud Educación ciencia y
tecnología relaciones exteriores defensa
cultura igualdad racial y Derechos
Humanos destacan entre los designados la
asignación del vicepresidente electo
Gerardo alquim en el Ministerio de
industrias y comercio exterior aniel
Franco hermana de la asesinada activista
Mariel y Franco y Silvio Almeida un
activista contra el racismo estarán al
frente de los departamentos de igualdad
racial y Derechos Humanos
respectivamente dos de sus hombres de
confianza figuran en la lista rui Costa
estará al frente del Ministerio de la
presidencia mientras que Fernando jadad
ex alcalde de Sao Paulo estará a cargo
de Hacienda El canciller será Mauro
vieira quien ya realizó estas funciones
bajo las órdenes de Dilma Rousseff Lula
anunció que aumentará 37 los ministerios
el actual gobierno cuenta con 23 no soy
yo quien necesita a los ministros que
anunciamos es el pueblo brasileño quien
los necesita los pobres las mujeres la
población negra nuestro compromiso es
con el pueblo y estoy seguro de que
sabremos cumplirlo aún no se conoce
quién dirigirá el Ministerio de medio
ambiente uno de los nombramientos más
esperados incluso a nivel internacional
y para terminar nos vamos hasta España
porque allí fue revelado el número
ganador de la tradicional lotería de
Navidad que repartió un total de 2500
millones de euros en diferentes premios
en diferentes puntos del país de esta
manera se da por iniciada la temporada
de fiestas de fin de año en España
Natalia plazas nos cuenta más
290 4 millones de euros
2400 90 4 millones la suerte fue echada
y ahora los Afortunados lo celebran en
muchos municipios de España los
ganadores de la lotería de Navidad
festejan su fortuna
muy muy muy especial es una alegría y no
puedo deciros nada más porque llevo me
voy a echar a llorar el premio mayor
conocido como el gordo quedó en manos de
muchos ciudadanos en varias regiones del
país el mismo número el
5.490 se vendió varias veces el bote
total alcanzó este año los 2520 millones
de euros un poco más que los 2.410
millones del año pasado la Euforia
también está presente entre los
vendedores celebran que el dinero se
quede entre sus comunidades
impresionante hemos repartido cinco
grandes premios el gordo de Navidad ha
vuelto a caer aquí en manises estamos
súper contentos al final ha sido el
gordo el cuarto premio y 305 premios en
total estamos ya os digo contentísimos
en verano que viene gente de fuera pero
si todo gente de clientes habituales
algún proveedor lo típico toda gente
conocida vamos y trabajadora claro los
Afortunados que pagaron por los boletos
20 euros serán recompensados con un pago
de 400.000 euros
325.000 tras el pago de impuestos por
cada papeleta que posean
son los alumnos del colegio de San
Ildefonso los encargados año tras año de
cantar los números ganadores y los
premios a todo el país
la lotería de Navidad inició en 1812
esta tradición ya centenaria marca el
inicio de la temporada navideña en el
país
Bueno este año no nos tocó el gordo por
acá sigan con más noticias en France
24.com y en France 24 con nuestra
programación feliz noche
[Música]